oh gary
do you want to try kung fu chess
we were just talking about it
okay maybe i'll play gung-fu chess with
gary as just like a a trial
oh okay
i'm ready oh we're
playing ah
okay so the way this works
is you make moves there's no turns
also sorry if it's kind of loud
we have
so this is chess without turns
and maybe it's less laggy now
oh this is kind of confusing let's take
a knight
take a bishop
take a pawn
ah sounds such fun sound effects
so basically
oh this is too much fun oh no oh no
what's going to happen here
wait what
okay i can take that thankfully
play this move
did this move
oh can i under promote tonight no it
didn't give me the option
let's take that rook
okay i think i'm gonna win this
so i have to take the king
oh this king is dead
okay so i'm going to take the king
oh that was so much fun
yeah there's a cool down so like when
you move a piece
you can't move that same piece for like
another five seconds
okay play again
okay so
yeah when you make a move there's a cool
down period
oh this is
yeah this is kind of insane
uh
that's probably not a great move there
for me
oh gary's improving
kind of
i'm just pushing all my pawns
no
please play queen d2 please oh no ah
oh so
oh well i hey i took the pawn in the
process
let's go
oh it's so fun
uh
so if i'm quick enough to play a move
and there's some intersection i still
get to play that move
and take whatever's in my way
i'm sure there's some edge cases though
okay that was fun
i'll go again
okay we'll do one more
i feel so dirty playing this game
[Music]
oh gary can bet channel points
oh you should bet for yourself
don't don't throw on purpose
oh no
no
yes
i don't have too many pawns left
is there an in this game
i want to promote a queen and then lose
oh no
what's going on
all my pieces are cooling down
wait it's some weird end game
who's this
oh i should have moved there before he
moved there
it's a fork coming up
oh no i'm kind of got forks there
oh this is so tricky
i should push my pawn
so
it so it's rook and knight vs rook
what's going on
oh i'm gonna win the rook though
i know i'm not
no
okay so i have to take the rook
wait what
[Music]
was king c3 oh
oh you tried to pre-move
that was such a hard-fought end game too
oh that's so much fun
such a cool game
yeah i guess in this game you can
the illegal moves you can make involve
leaving your king undefended so the game
doesn't end in mate and it ends in
taking the king
yeah i'll have to put this on youtube
chess without turns
it's a cool concept and you can't do
this otp
unless you could
if we did this otb i don't know how that
would work
you'd have to do it with where the
pieces are like uh
they have sand in it and it's a sand
oh yes my kung fu
yeah this probably should have been a
draw but it's so weird to
like adjust because
there's not only the position you have
to worry about but it's all like the
whole timing with the cooldown
it just adds another layer of complexity
that you're not used to
i'm down for one more if you want to do
one more
oh i feel like this could be addictive
though okay oh no
[Music]
okay we're going full yolo on hungary
here
i should keep in mind what pawns that
i've moved already
wow
i feel so powerful here
okay so i got the rook
oh no
oh no not another one of these
oh no knight a4 was such a good move too
oh no i'm in trouble
no
he could have taken my king though
wow i'm alive my god
what just happened
he wants to fork me
we're at a standstill
oh i don't know what to do
i only get forked
takes check
i guess i can get away with this
it's close though
i should
he's not forking me okay
interesting
hey
i'll deliver a check
oh he wants to play knight c5
clicking here just for the
strategy
i'm gonna turn down the music
okay
gary's not even playing
what happens if i check him
i was hoping for king he would see my
rook coming and he would play king c5
he has to be careful now
oh i see his strategy
i can play hiron
wait what hi youtube
he forgot to move
gary was busy trash talking in chat
i'm so confused
oh it kicked you out
oh
did he
he oh he disconnected
it paired you with someone oh wow
so gary got disconnected
i thought he was just stalling
i thought he was stalling and
waiting for me to actually take the king
i thought he was being so
devious oh that's so funny
oh it says gary oh he thought he won by
mate
no you have to win by taking the king
oh that's kind of funny
okay i think we'll end it there